Now, did you enjoy that session? Or did you enjoy that session, sweetie?
Good. I'm so glad. Let me get you out now. You've been tied up for a while now, huh?
Uh, what if I just...
Uh, that's strange.
Oh, just normally I don't do the knot in the rope like this.
I might have been a bit preoccupied with you, huh?
That's not like me to make such a mistake.
My nails are making this harder than usual. I knew I shouldn't have gotten them this long.
Do you want now? Oh, no. I just can't cut the rope. That's not the right thing to do, silly.
These ropes are invaluable to me. If I went cutting through all my equipment, I'd have none left now.
Would I? Your skin isn't too marked at all, either.
I made sure not to make them too tight, at least.
So, just give me a few moments while I wrestle away with this.
I'll have you out in no time. I promise.
I've had some sessions run over 12 hours, so it's not like your limbs are gonna fall off or anything.
Uh, no. Not at all.
My goodness. Did it really make such a big mistake?
I wonder when I did it. Was it when you started doing that thing I like?
Normally I'm so focused, so I guess this situation is a compliment to you, after all.
Okay, what if I just...
What about here?
Dammit.
Okay.
If I just...
No.
Oh, no.
What if...
No, no. That won't do.
No, no.
Maybe...
Hmm.
What if...
Wait.
I do?
No, I don't want it.
Come on.
What if I...
Ugh.
If I...
Is this it?
Ugh, no.
Come on.
Wait, wait, wait.
I got it.
Wait, no, I didn't get it.
Just a moment, sweetie.
I swear, I'm almost done.
If I just...
What about here?
Wait.
Oh, no. That's not it, either.
Well...
Okay.
Right there?
No.
Okay.
Almost...
There.
Oh, man.
Ugh.
No.
Mm-mm.
Oh, this is so frustrating.
Ugh.
Come on.
Just...
Come on, nod.
Give me a good little nod.
Hmm.
Ugh.
Mm-hmm.
Gotta be fine.
No.
What about this?
Ugh, I didn't do anything, either.
Mm-hmm.
If I could just...
Ah, these nails are impossible.
But on this side...
Mm-hmm.
Almost...
There.
I was so close.
Mm-hmm.
I need to get my nails shorter next time.
Well...
I have to be somewhere, so...
I'll see you later.
Mm-hmm.